dangereuse usé les dalles 17 mar ne
seront bientôt plus qu'un souvenir à
elancourt avec la création d'une école
de musique à la place de l'ancien centre
oecuménique la mairie et saint quentin
en yvelines ont souhaité rajeunir le
centre ville les commerçants se
plaignaient effectivement de problèmes
d'éclairage se plaignait aussi de l'état
de la dalle qui faisait qu'il y avait un
certain nombre de personnes qui avait
été accidenté en tombant nous avions
nous-mêmes un certain nombre de
courriers que nous avions reçues en ce
sens pour nous il y avait une volonté de
leur donner la possibilité de re
dynamiser l'aspect économique de cette
de cette dalle début du chantier janvier
les pavés seront remplacés par un enrobé
de bitume rouge décorés par des notes de
musique un éclairage nocturne viendra
compléter cette création en faisant
apparaître des gammes sur le sol un
moyen d'améliorer la sécurité et
l'hygiène de l'espace le sud japon mais
une fois j'ai un souvenir devant la
boulangerie qu'il ya un petit décalage
d'au moins 4,5 centimes en est jeté
entre le manuel départ j'ai poussé un
peu trop vite et j'ai basculé
parce que ça fait sale et que c'est un
peu un salut le niveau de dand sous
puisque ça c'est pas stable et qu'il y a
de l'eau donc à un moment où ça dépend
de la température ça sent pas bon
un nouveau système de sécurité avec des
alarmes sera aussi mise en place pour
les commerçants coût des travaux pour la
dalle plus de 2 millions d'euros
le projet devrait être terminé pour fin